bonsoir très cher magnifique actrice qui
est nommé dans cette catégorie
je suis vraiment très très heureuse que
vous soyez nommé car quand je vois qui
vous est statistiquement ce n'était pas
gagné
en france les femmes de plus de 40 ans
représentent 51% de la population et 8%
des rôles 10% des rôles pas du temps de
présence à l'écran là où doit être à peu
près à 2 2 et demi pour cent ce qui a
pour résultat que ne sont visibles en
fait de femmes ayant dépassé le stade de
denrées périssables cependant que les
hommes se bonifie d'année en année ne
sont visibles dans l'espace public que
quasiment muriel pénicaud et elisabeth
burana ce qui est dommage c'est dommage
parce qu'elles ne sont pas
représentatives elles ne sont pas
représentatifs de ce que l'on sait des
femmes après 30 ans qui est qu'elle
s'occupe essentiellement de prendre soin
des enfants des malades des personnes
âgées des autres de la société tandis
que ces deux là par exemple très visible
s'occupe essentiellement de détruire
chaque jour un peu plus la société en
trouvant que c'est une bonne idée
justement là maintenant de faire une
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
précipitera encore plus dans la misère
2,2 millions d'intérimaires et de
précaires qui travaillent dans tous les
domaines de la société nous le savons
bien et aussi dans le monde du cinéma et
de voter cette loi de réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui entérine le
principe de non assistance à personne en
danger
au sommet de l'état tandis que vous
merveilleux
qui sait pas mais qui est né ce soir
vous avez fait exactement tout le
contraire de ça vous avez mis toute la
force de votre âme tout votre talent et
dieu sait qu'il est grand tout votre
sensibilité toute votre fantaisie toutes
vos contradictions au service de
personnages qu'on appelle des seconds
rôles qui plus second rôle parmi les
second rôles puisque féminin et sans qui
aucune histoire n'est possible bravo
merci
[Applaudissements]